NATHAN NAZE: So this is
the Closure Library talk.
We're starting a little
late, because the main
session went over.
My name is Nathan Naze.
I am an Engineer at Google.
I have a day job--it is
Google Books, where
I am a UI Engineer.
Google Books is one of the
users of Closure Tools in
general and specifically
Closure Library which is what
the talk is about today.
I'm not sure that everybody is
familiar with Closure Library;
we will spend some time at the
beginning just going over what
it is and then how to use it.
View live notes and ask
questions about this about
the session on Google Wave:
there's a bit.ly link.
Can everybody read that it's
-- we can do this, if not.
Right there if you want to type
that in and you have a laptop,
there's also a Google
Moderator on there.
I've looked through the
questions already and we will
go through those and we
also do Q&A at the end.
So there's three major parts to
this talk: the three parts are
What is Closure Library,
Getting started with
Closure Library, and
the reference manual.
What is the Closure Library is
basically just going to go over
the Library itself -- talk
about the history
of the project.
Getting started with Closure
Library will actually just do a
brief overview of how it works
and how it's set up, and then
also a demo of how to get it
working and using an
actual application.
And then the reference manual
is just going on -- a brief
overview of the Library.
It's inconceivable that we
actually go through every
module and everything and go
like that, but when you get
home, you will like to do that.
We'll talk about some of
the more out there points.
So what is Closure Library?
This is the most
important question.
It's Google's "Standard
Library" for JavaScript.
Most applications at Google --
gmail -- so the icons are at
the bottom: gmail, sites, docs
books, reader, blogger,
calendar -- that's not
exhaustive -- maps actually
uses it now -- are written
on Closure Library.
They use Closure
Library as a base.
So that means they're actually
-- these are applications that
are written in JavaScript.
One of the issues is that
JavaScript is a dynamic
language that isn't
particularly well known for its
readability or modularization,
and so part of what Closure
Library is doing is
attempting to solve that.
With Closure Compiler, which is
also one of the Closure tools,
it's a typed object-oriented
means of collaboratively
developing complex
web applications.
So these teams that we're
working on, these large
JavaScript applications --
they're not a single developer.
They're people that -- they are
large teams that work
collaboratively; we use source
control; people have to be able
to read your code and
understand what's happening.
So and as I said, it's the
JavaScript Library behind
Google's web apps.
So problems we are trying to
solve with Closure Library:
like I said, large-scale web
development--where you're
working on large teams,
when you're working on
complex applications.
So as part of that the tools
themselves--JavaScript, HTML,
CSS, the DOM--these are
meant for web documents.
Like the early days of the web
are about creating a document,
you build up from there, how
do you script the thing?
It's about modifying the DOM;
it's about -- it's not
necessarily made for these
large complex applications.
So how do we use those as
tools, but in such a way
that we can stay sane.
So as far as collaborative
development goes, what
we're concerned about is
maintenance and readability.
These are applications that
we're going to write and going
to maintain, and we're going to
have people coming out of the
project that haven't used it in
the past, that haven't read it
in the past, that have to be
able to go look at the code,
see what's going on -- we need,
you know, we need a high
degree of readability.
We have -- like most languages
at Google, we have a style
guide that we -- so that people
-- that we require people to
stick with, and you'll actually
notice that, if you look at the
source of Closure Library now,
it's also very well-documented
in terms of comments on the
code JSDoc, which is actually
something we will get into
in a bit.
PEARL is often derided as a
language that is write-only,
that you can't read somebody
else's code when you go back.
And one of the problems is that
JavaScript does not necessarily
have a great reputation for
readability or clear style, and
it will vary across projects.
One of the other issues about
-- I mentioned in the previous
slide, Closure Library is the
standard library for Google.
Unlike a lot of languages, the
best case I think of is Python,
which the quote is "comes
with the batteries
included." It has a
standard library that
it's shipped with.
JavaScript doesn't have that.
It has things in the global
scope--some very basic things;
it's not a lot of
functionality; what's exposed
in the browser is an additional
API into the DOM,
but that's about it.
So there's a lot of, like,
common infrastructure that
isn't necessarily a part of the
language, and it isn't standard
library and so, you end up with
this proliferation of different
tool kits and different
frameworks, etc.
Managing complexity:
So additional to that the
development life cycle is of
concern to us; we care about
being able to maintain
code in the future.
Managing complexity is
important to us I don't,
want to know about all the
internals of the class.
You'll actually see this
when we look at the code.
But the way that Closure
Library components and
classes are written is
very object-oriented.
It's kind of -- it's
not procedural.
And this is -- partially is
-- out of encapsulation.
We want to hide the internals
of the things that we're
writing; we want to hide the
internals so that I only
these objects as interfaces.
This is just classic
object-oriented development.
But that helps us work
collaboratively, because I
write a class, I expose an
interface on it, you write a
class, you expose an interface.
None of us have to care
about what's below that.
Modularization and Conventions.
So, Closure Library, as I'll
get into, is very broad.
It's not like a classic
JavaScript Library, which is a
monolithic thing that you
include, and then all of the
sudden, there is an API exposed
in a global namespace, rather
there's a namespacing system,
and I'll get into that.
But you pull from it what you
want, and that's very important
to us in terms of speed,
because we want the code
over the wire to be
as small as possible.
We do that in two ways.
One is to just pull what you
want from Closure Library, and
then secondly, in combination
with Closure Compiler, which
we'll get into, we want
to make that minified.
We want -- the Closure Compiler
does more excellent stuff like
dropping dead code, in-lining
the functions, but we
will get into that.
And finally, testing
and stability.
One thing about Google
development is that everything
is continuously integrated; we
don't push versions
of Closure Library.
You have it as part
of your project.
You build it through
the Closure Compiler.
You send that out, but as
part of that, there is a
suite of tests that run.
We run it as a continuous build
inside of Google; we run it as
a submit-queue before you
submit things into Closure
Library, so that all the tests
are working all the time.
The other advantage of that is
stability: that you can trust
that things won't
break over time.
So Closure Library--let's
give some of the history.
Starting in 2005, there has
never been anybody staffed
on Closure Library.
Like I said, my day job
is Google Books; my 20%
is Closure Library.
Actually open-sourcing it was
an effort we wanted to do for
a long time -- myself and
an Engineer in Sydney,
Australia, Daniel Nadasi.
This was our 20% project last
year, and we open-sourced it
in November of last year.
I think, at last count, at
least 400 Engineers at Google
have contributed at least one
change-list to Closure Library.
It's also the focus
of the talk.
It's about -- not that lines
of code is a good measure of
anything, but it's about 250
lines of JavaScript, not
including the tests,
so it's not small.
Closure Compiler, which we'll
get into more deeply, but
conceptually it's a JavaScript
to JavaScript compiler.
We're not going from a source
language to a target language,
we're going from source input
to a minified -- for those of
you that have worked on web
development, you go from --
you're familiar with minifiers
that are taking a source,
renaming variables, doing
things just trying to get it
smaller, stripping
comments, etc.
It's doing all that, but
it's doing a lot more.
It's actually doing a full
parse -- developing a parse
tree, doing transformations on
that to both minify, but also
to take an unused code to check
types, which is important, and
we'll get into it later -- and
make that the output of it,
which we refer to as a
job as [? grabinary ?]
as small as possible, because
that's what matters in terms of
speed: getting that thing over
the wire and getting
it executed.
The third component of Closure
Tools is Closure Templates.
This is used in some of our
-- very heavily in gmail.
It's basically a templating
language that has both a server
-- a Java server implementation
and also the JavaScript
implementation in
-- for the client.
So you can send out a template,
fill it, it renders out
as HTML, and then you can
use that on your client.
Closure Library itself --
so like I said, namespaces
allow for a broad library.
If we look at the source
itself, it includes a lot,
including the kitchen sink.
There's everything from -- the
funny example that we always
use is there's a quad-tree
implementation, just in
case you needed that in
your web development.
Most people don't some; people
have, but all to a widget set.
So if you go look through the
demos, you'll actually see a
lot of the widgets that you're
familiar with from a lot of the
Google apps, because that's the
ones they are using, and we
care about this in two ways.
We care that there's
consistency across UI, across
different applications, but we
also like to share code,
because that's how
we identify bugs.
This is the third point there.
More users means
more found bugs.
As we reuse these components,
we identify things that change
or things that aren't working
correctly and somebody
goes in and fixes it.
It's Linus' Law, what is the
exact quote? "Given enough
eyes, all bugs are
shallow." Because we have
so many clients using Closure
Library, it helps us to find
and identify these
things early.
The middle point, types and
type-checking: like I said, the
style of this is actually quite
-- rather different than what
you see in a lot of JavaScript,
which tends to be
very procedural.
Take this div, style it this
way, push it over here, animate
it, whatever it happens to be.
If you actually look at these
things -- if you actually look
at the code, it's -- JavaScript
has a -- for people coming in
from other languages, it has
this prototype-based
inheritance scheme, which is a
little boring, but I'll show an
example of the code.
But the thing about that is
we're actually doing
type-enforcement by Closure
Compiler, what's referred to as
type-hinting, so JSDoc that
exists on the top of -- the
JSDoc that sits above methods
is actually specifying: these
are the names of the
parameters, these are the types
we're expecting This is, in the
case of a constructor, it's
actually saying: this is of
type whatever, it extends this
and the Closure Compiler
actually takes that all in,
understands it, develops the
inheritance tree, and then does
all forms of type-checking,
which is essential when you're
doing these large applications
where I want to know if I'm
giving a function a type that
is wrong, and that happens all
the time in dynamic languages.
Eventually when you get to a
large enough project, you're
documenting in the doc-stream
what the types are
anyway, right?
So why not make that formal.
So part of the development of
this is it's geared towards
complex collaborative
UI development.
Why I use Closure Library then?
It's modular and broad, like I
said, geared for complex
applications and implements
type-safety on top of
JavaScript, which isn't
necessary strong in that suit,
very stable and tested.
It's what runs many Google web
appls today, and it works
well with Closure Compiler.
Fair point, why not
use Closure Library?
I won't stay on this slide too
long, but it is a steeper
learning curve, it's a more
complex way of doing
development, and it's actually
very much geared towards a
complex -- it's very much
geared for creating
complex web applications.
It's lower level when you
look at it; it's not
about it exposing a small
understandable API.
There's modulars all over
the place, they all have
individual interfaces.
It's great in that respect, but
if what you want to do is pull
up a div, style it, animate it
across, there are a lot of
toolkits that do that very
well, and I would encourage you
to use them, because they
do a great job of it.
Use the right tool for the job.
So for some people this is
overkill; for some people, this
takes care of a lot of the
problems that are inherent
in web development today.
And obviously we do this
because we are working
with these large
complex applications.
But it's part of that, while
we're doing it, this is part
of the impetus for why we
wanted to open-source it.
We want to continue to develop
this library, but we also
want to do it in the open.
And so that was the reason
that we wanted to open-source
it in the first place.
So, let me quickly go over the
namespacing system, as you can
tell, because it's
on the slide here.
Namepaces 101.
So if you look at any Closure
Library -- if you look at any
file in Closure Library, you'll
see the first things at the top
-- probably first you'll see a
copyright statement and then a
license statement, but then the
first thing at the top you will
see is goog.provide, which is a
message that's saying,
hey I'm providing this
namespace at the top.
So for those of you familiar
with other languages,
this is not a novel idea.
But basically these are
the two ways that we
express dependency.
So when I say goog.provide(&qu
ot;foo.bar") it means I'm
providing this namespace, this
file provides this namespace;
goog.require says, I
require this namespace.
So for this to run, I need this
loaded and this loaded and
this loaded and this loaded.
The result is a giant
dependency tree.
Hopefully a dependency tree
and not a dependency cycle
anywhere, because that makes
it hard to figure it out.
This is unlike single
file libraries.
So one of the questions that we
get on the discussion list is
like, hey this is cool, why
can't I just pull it in
with the Ajax loader.
So google Ajax loader is
the thing that will pull
a certain version of whatever
JavaScript library.
It doesn't make sense here;
it's not applicable, because
inherently you are just pulling
a subset of the Closure
Library, just the parts you use
and then passing that on to --
in production, you're passing
it on to the Closure Compiler,
so you are actually building a
separate JS binary for your
application when you are doing
this, pull a sub-tree
of what you use.
This is an example.
This is actually pulled right
out of goog.math, which is one
of the lower level things for
just mathematical functions.
Like I said, there's no
standard library in JavaScript,
so we're defining all sorts of
low level structures, like
range, rect, size, coordinate,
box, which are very useful, for
example, in the style class to
be able to express and
understand something as
a box or rectangle.
But goog.math provides --
goog.math is a number of static
functions; goog.math.range, I
think, is one of them,
and then these are the
requirements on it.
So when I say in my file
goog.require(goog.math) it's
going to go to this file, see
all these other required
statements, fan out,
grab those as well.
And so, the result is a
dependency tree, and this
is just -- I omitted
goog.math on these.
So math.array, math.size,
math.rect, math.range -- this
is what you saw before actually
expressed as a dependency tree.
So if I were to include just,
for example, on this one well
actually, I have a
mouse-pointer -- if I am just
including math.rect, what
that's going to require is
well, it's going to do the
transitive dependency in the
tree: math.box,
math.coordinate, those ones
will get pulled.
Hopefully that makes
sense conceptually.
Because we're going to go into
a larger -- so when you
actually think about this, I
was just doing goog.math, there
are I don't know how many
modules there are in Closure
Library right now -- the actual
dependency tree, I think it's
the base one is like 500
or 600 individual files.
So the actual dependency tree
is very large, and if I were
to grab it right now, it
would not fit on a slide.
So we're working with
a reduced example.
Let's say you have an
application which is green
here, so foo application.
I'm saying, so with this guy on
the right, it says I'm going to
depend on this guy; this guy's
going to depend on both this
guy and this guy, right?
And so, when we actually do the
dependency analysis, it's only
going to pull what's required
and so with what turned gray
there, are the things from
which there's no path
down from in the tree.
And so when we actually build
this, when we actually use it
in production, we're just
pulling those dots that are
actually required, and we doing
that in dependency order,
dependency order being defined
as anything that is required is
loaded before it's needed.
So you wind up with a list,
basically, of files.
We'll get into a more practical
example that second.
Type checking-- just to
introduce the concept:
"stronger-typed"
JavaScript.
For those of you that like
reading JavaScript version
stuff, there have been
attempts, at least introducing
some concepts of typing into
future versions of JavaScript,
but as far as it works at
Google and within Closure
tools, Bob we're doing it
with JSDoc, so the JSDoc
we're already adding.
In the early days of JavaScript
at google, we were adding it
anyway, because we needed to
know that this is this
function--it's expecting
an array; this is the
function that's expecting
whatever it might be.
But the Closure Compiler, which
is actually, to those of you
familiar with rhino, which was
a project to do a JavaScript
implementation in java; it's
actually using that same code
to build this parse tree, and
it's also scanning those JSDoc
comments to understand what
the inputs to a method or
function are supposed to be.
So it's essential to the
collaboration: one is
self-documenting code--I want
to know how to use this and the
types tell me how to do that;
encapsulation, like I said
previously, it's important for
us to define these interfaces
-- two things, and then
not worry about the
implementation underneath.
As far as when I am interacting
with a class -- I mean this is
classic object-oriented job --
this is classic object-oriented
design, but I want to hide the
complexities of how things
are actually implemented.
I only want to interact with it
as an object, because these
code bases are so big, and
nobody could conceivably know
everything about everything.
And so part of that is we're
introducing concepts of
private, public, protected that
you see in other languages, but
we're actually doing that
in JavaScript, and it's
enforced by the Compiler.
And as I said, how is
this actually done --
as I said, JSDoc tags.
So for those of you familiar
with java, there's java.doc --
there are tools that take
java.doc, turn it into
nice HTML pages.
We actually also have a tool
that does this and have
generated documentation
for the Closure Library.
So the typed annotations are
enforced by Closure Compiler.
phrase we use is "type
hinting." So these are
not required to use Closure
Compiler, and if you sit
through a Closure Compiler
talk, they'll get into this
more, but if we have type
information, and we see that
you're passing at something
that is not valid as was
defined in JSDoc, there
will be a warning.
And actually for many projects
using Closure Library at
Google, we actually have
pre-submit set up, so that we
don't allow any warnings to pop
up for our projects, because
we don't want -- it's
indicative of a problem.
Either you are doing
the wrong thing or the
annotations are wrong.
So let's use a
concrete example.
This was taken from
good.math.sum, which is from
the goog.math that I was
talking about before.
Brief note: goog is kind of
like the base name that we use
for things, so goog dot
whatever, goog dot, and it also
is representative of the
directory structure.
So here, this is a function
of the goog.math namespace.
What it's saying is -- I mean,
obviously, what some does is
return the sum of
the arguments.
The first parameter, which is
variable arguments is the
numbers to add; the
documentation -- this is
documented on the Closure
Compiler site -- the
documentation is taking --
I'm taking a variable
number of numbers.
So when you call this thing,
it's actually going to check
that that's the case, and then
what I'm returning is a number
that is the sum of the
arguments, makes sense?
So that when I'm using this in
code, the Compiler's going to
say, when I call this I want to
check that everything is right
when it goes in, and then the
result that I get back, we're
expecting, is the number.
And when I use that to call
other things, it's also going
to be doing that checking,
which is pretty cool.
Similar, let me talk about a
user-defined -- let me -- when
I say user-defined, I mean not
inherent in the JavaScript
language when I am introducing
a type that is not native.
So for example, this is
a UI widget called
good.ui.DatePicker.
The two that are in red there,
a constructor, this is saying
that this is an instantiable
object and extends goog.ui to a
component, which is one of the
base classes in the
UI sub-directory.
Most things in UI are at least
a sub-class of goog.ui to that
component, but what's important
about saying extends, is that
this tells the Closure Compiler
that goog.ui.DatePicker is a
sub-class of goog.ui component,
and so when I say that I need
goog.ui component as the
parameter that's going into
something else, that the
Closure Compiler is like, oh
cool, well goog.ui.DatePicker
is a sub-class, and so
everything is cool, no warning.
This is important.
So let's talk a little bit
more about Closure Compiler.
I went
over it briefly, but hopefully
everybody gets the basic idea.
What we care about is that
as a basic thing, it
lowers code size.
It shrinks code size.
So this is the basis step that
a minifier does, like renaming
-- removing dead codes -- or
renaming, is the basic thing,
but what it also does is remove
dead codes, inlines functions,
and more -- and then code
checking -- checks types,
function/method calls, syntax
errors -- it'll grab that
before the browser does, and as
we pointed out, it understands
user-defined types.
For those of you that
are visual learners,
there is a big box.
So basically, on the left, I
used green and red, and just
similar to what we did in the
tree before; green being your
application code, red being
whatever Closure Compiler
modules you're taking in.
We say Closure Compiler -- we'd
like to pile these as input.
It goes into Closure Compiler
and does a full parse --
understands it as a full
parse-tree, does whatever
optimizations it wants to, and
pops out the yellow one, which
is the JS binary, and
that guy is small.
So getting started
with Closure Library.
So, Closure Library exists as
a project that's hosted on
code.google.com, so it's just
an SVN project I should also
mention that all the Closure
tools are here, on Closure
Tools, and then ours is
Library, which has links off
to everything you need.
So we hosted in on SVN So how
to get it: click on source;
let's go to the terminal; close
this; remove trunk for now.
So what we are doing here -- so
SVN check-out: and that's just
pulling -- I just wanted to
show what one does to check
out Closure Library.
It's going, pulling this all
from the SVN repository.
The way that this actually
works in production -- this
gives you an idea of how many
JavaScript files and things
there are in Closure Library,
because it's going to
grab them right now.
But the way that this works
internally is that our work is
-- we're checking it into
Perforce, which is the
canonical for Closure Library,
and then we're taking a
snapshot of pushing
that to SVN.
So one of the things that we're
working on right now and
actually if you go into OSCON,
Dan Bentley -- who I'm not sure
if he's here -- is working on
tools to do this in the general
case, so we built it once for
Closure Compiler; he's doing it
in the general case, to make
tools to make the problem of
going from Perforce to an
external repository easier, and
then also the reverse: taking
patches to the SVN repository
or whatever respository it
happens to be externally, and
migrate them into Perforce.
So the point I should make
here: SVN externals if you're
using SVN, so when you do a
sync, you can set up SVN
externals to be able to pull
Closure Library as well as a
dependency, and so when you
sync it will also pull
updates to Closure Compiler
-- er -- Closure Library.
And then continuous
integration--some people are
confused -- I mentioned this
earlier -- some people are
confused that we're not
doing the versions.
We just update the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
We find bugs; we fix them.
And so when you're working
as well, SVN externals is
a great way of doing this,
but just be tracking ahead.
So one other point is
server agnosticism.
There are all sorts of
front-ends at Google.
There are Java
front-ends, there are C
front-ends -- that's what I
work on -- there are Python
front-ends, and so nothing
about Closure is tied to
any of these set-ups.
The negatives of that is that
you're responsible for the
glue, there's a small amount of
work to get it serving Closure
Library files, and then also to
hook this into the Compiler.
It's not that hard; I'm
going to do it on stage.
How to get started: there is a
base file--it's called base.js,
what that does is it sets
up the loading system.
It loads a file called deps.js,
which is expressing where all
the modules are -- what all the
modules are, and what files
they live in, so that when you
require it can go fetch them.
It does it
-- if you actually look at the
file itself,
goog.addDependency, it says the
path, the namespaces it
provides, and the ones that
it requires.
User-defined namespaces use
the same tools to make
their own dependency files.
So if you're introducing your
own modules, there's
documentation of this online,
but you'll also generate deps
files to tell Closure Library,
"I'm introducing foo
dot whatever, it lives
in this file."
So, how this actually works in
your stuff is include a path
to base.js and the possible
additional deps files as I just
mentioned -- but let's not
worry about that right now --
and then the path to my code.
So let's do an example.
So like I said, I just grabbed
Closure Library, right here, so
that I just checked it into
trunk right here, if we
actually go to trunk,
everything that you see
in the library today.
I'm just going to set up a
Python server that serves out
of my current directory, and
then pop open my browser, local
host, so trunk is right here,
this is Closure Library as
you'd see it today, and this is
the namespacing that we have of
everything, but what I
did for this talk is put
together a brief demo.
So let me also bring
that up in eMacs.
Demo -- can't type -- demo to
HTML -- so this is just a
simple static HTML file; it's
pulling in a lot of CSS, as
those of you that are familiar
with HTML can tell, and then
doing what I said before:
pulling in base.js, pulling in
the invites, and then just some
simple HTML to bring up a
little form to fill out.
That form is -- I wrote an
application; I named it
Nathan's invite because
that's my first name;
I'm clever that way.
So this is -- just as a static
page -- it's not doing
anything special.
I haven't done anything,
I'm not using Closure
Library right now.
The date is May 19th, boring
boring, in 2010, time, who am
I inviting, write a little
invitation, click the go
button, just as an example.
So at the bottom of this file,
hopefully everybody can read
this; I have a little call that
I have commented out right now
that's called invites.start.
Let's un-comment that;
save it; go back; load.
And then it's actually if I go
to -- so this is actually
instead of doing what it did
before, which is basically just
a static file, it's pulling in
the DatePicker, it allows me to
pick a date, fills those things
for me, picks a time: 1 p.m.,
who am I inviting, it's using
the auto-complete widget, which
is already -- which is
already pre-filled with some
examples, so Harry S.
Truman, buddy of mine, Thoreau,
Hank Aaron -- those guys are
coming to my birthday party and
-- Having a Birthday Party,
Hope You Can Make It.
And then this is actually using
the rich text editor, which is
actually the same one that you
see in gmail, which actually
-- when we said we were
open-sourcing Closure Library,
there was a push by that team
to get that checked in so it
would go out, and it's actually
been a very popular part of
Closure Library--people
just trying to get that.
So, normal, make it huge, click
that and the invite is set,
which is just a static form,
but if you had an actual
application, you would go off
and do whatever server
side-work you had to do.
So let's look at how
that actually worked.
Like I said, I had a script tag
here called invites.js It goes
off and fetches that file.
Let's just look at it, and at
the top, I'm defining
invites.start, you can see as
I was talking before,
goog.provide.invites.start, all
that it requires, so these are
all the things that it was
using to do that demo.
What's happening is that I'm
loading this file; it's hitting
all the other requires; it's
fanning out and doing the
dependency tree thing that I
was talking about before.
And then when I get to the
bottom of this file,
invites.start is started.
And so it's just doing four
things: set up the DatePicker,
set up timeselect, set up
auto-complete, set up editor,
and you're actually looking at
this thing, you can read about
what I'm actually doing
to fill these out.
One great way to get an
understanding of how to use
these is to look at the demos
directory; so if I go to -- so
like I said, I checked
out trunk, right.
The demos directory is right
here, which is just doing
common UI controls.
It says pull out a button.
Pull out button -- there
you go, how to use
a button, whatever.
But if you look at the source
-- oh, this is doing a frame --
so if we open this guy in a new
tab and we look at the source,
you can actually just go look
and see what they're doing, as
well, which is a great way to
just learn about the thing and
how it's actually used in
practice, makes sense?
And then the one other thing
that I will do is -- let's go
back to the demo -- so I talked
about Closure Compiler, so this
is all -- so actually let
me go back to the slide.
This is all using just what we
understand is the de-bug loader
that we described before.
There's the de-bug loader,
which does essentially what
I described: get to a point
and go fetch the additional
files that are necessary.
The problem is you'd never
actually want to do
this in practice.
It's a horrible idea to do this
in practice, because it's
requiring an extra HDP request
for each time you are
loading a module.
So if you're -- it's not
inconceivable that there are
200 to 300 files in a large,
very complex application--gmail
probably is much larger than
that--and so when in
production, we want to compile
it down both so that it's a
single JavaScript binary, or in
the case of some of the apps,
it's actually pulling multiple
modules, it's pulling what's
necessary to bootstrap and then
additional things, but that's
Closure Library 201,
which is next semester.
But so there's essentially two
modes: de-bug, which we just
demonstrated, and then
compiled, where we are actually
taking the sources and we're
feeding them to the Compiler,
the Compiler is giving us
output to create our js binary,
and we're using that
in production.
So when you're a starter.
You want to do
debug.
There's a couple of reasons
to do debug: one it's
faster, JavaScript uses
interpretive language.
If you're running on local
host, 200 requests over
HEDP is not a big deal.
So but the more important thing
is that you want to be able to
use your own debugger; you want
to be able to use whatever
tools you're using, and when
you're making an edit, you
want to just be able to hit
refresh and see that happen.
You also want to be able to --
when you're using a debugger,
you can set break statements,
you can use console.log
statements, all sorts
of things like that.
Compile mode.
It's run through Closure
Compiler; in most cases
this is one big file.
It's small over the wire, and
dependency tools prepare
your compiler input, which
I'm about to show you.
The tools that we have to use
this -- the first one we
released with Closure Compiler
is calcdeps, which was what
youtube used, because they
didn't necessarily use the same
build system that the rest of
the -- that apps written on
top of closure tools used.
That's a legacy.
There is a more recent
implementation, which is little
cleaner called Closure Builder.
There is an effort to
build the support of
the Closure Compiler.
One of the things that we'd
like about that is to have
better support for non-UNIX
operating systems, because a
lot of the development at
Google is assuming that
you're doing things on
UNIX at the command line.
So let me show you an example
of this: so the same
demo that we had before.
Let's kill that server.
So Compiler -- this is -- if
I go into Compiler, this is
just a check-out of
Compiler at Head.
It's just a jar, for those
of you who that know
how those work.
But what I want to be able to
do is -- what I'm doing here is
-- if you look at this trunk
closure builder, it is
expressing two routes.
Let me highlight as I
talk -- expressing three
routes, I'm sorry.
It's expressing the root
of the Closure Library.
It says, go search for all the
Closure Library, find all the
models you see in there, look
through the third party
closure, which is another -- we
have some We have some amount
of third party code that we
could pull into Closure Library
that we want to also scan, and
then the route, the
files that I wrote.
The input is demo'd at invites,
that's the top of our tree.
The output mode is compiled;
I actually want to
see compiled output.
The flag is compiler
jar--that's where the jar is
actually sitting, and the
compiler flags I want to add on
that are advanced optimization.
So I wanted to do the full
sweep of -- not only do I want
minification, but I want your
code-dropping, I want you to
make this js binary as
small as possible.
So if I run that,
you see it work.
What it's doing in Python, is
it's going and scanning all the
files that I just described,
creating this giant dependency
tree, picking up that top one,
generating that sub-tree of the
whole mess that I just created,
and then sending that
to Closure Compiler.
And now it's thinking.
So, right there is the output.
If you look at any Google
application, you'll actually
see the same thing, where if
you look at the source tag,
it's this massive code.
This actually is written by
humans, but it's gone through
the minifier, it's gone through
the Compiler, to get it as
small as possible when we
send it over the wire.
So what we can do is just take
the output of that and put it
into compile.js, but like a
cooking program, I've
already done this.
So if I go to my demo, I look
at compile.js as just a --
compile.js is the output of
the Closure Compiler,
and we go to eMacs.
We go to invites.html, and
instead of loading this source
thing like we did before, let's
just cut that out, and
compiled.js, go back to my demo
-- oops, I killed the Python
server -- start the server
again, go back to my demo,
reload it, and then now, it's
actually not doing this
by requesting each
module individually.
It's requesting that one
big file that obfuscated
JavaScript binary that I
was talking about before.
And everything works
the same as it did.
So this is what you would
actually want to do in
production, and then I
go invite my friends.
So, that's that.
And then finally, the
reference manual.
It's inconceivable that we
are going to go through the
entirety of the library today,
but I will do this briefly.
Like I said, the code base
of self-generated docs; we
actually go through the js.docs
and -- I'm having trouble
getting to this server today,
but we actually go through the
js.docs and create a generated
HTML view of all of these, and
so this is actually an SVN
repository at SVN -- it's in
the doc directory at the route.
But, one of the things that is
event-driven programming, many
things are sub-classes
of event targets.
So, like nodes, you can
actually put listeners onto
these objects; they express
event, they say, "I'm a
button and I have been clicked,
I've done whatever." It's
not just necessarily
just DOM nodes.
We're providing basic utilities
, which is, you know,
JavaScript primitives working
with arrays, working with
objects, things like that.
DOM utilities, we're dealing
with the DOM; style utilities
on top of that; network
utilities, be able to do -- you
know -- XML, HTTP requests;
being able to do JSON P, I-O.
There is some amount -- the
actual class that's used, for
example, in gmail chat to have
a long-lived connection with
the server is in there.
All sorts of things like that,
it's a very broad library.
Naming conventions.
So the namespaces I described
before, goog.dom is going to be
found in the DOM folder; style,
in style folder; Xhrio -- it
just maps out -- that's
the convention.
There is no reason it needs
to be like that, but
we do it for clarity.
Like I say, basic utilities,
array, string, math, object,
uri, basic things for
manipulating url's,
things like that.
Data structures -- oops, I
meant to click on that -- this
is actually doing -- this
is actually all the
implementations of data
structures that are in there.
I should be able to do -- for
whatever reason it didn't come
up before, but this is actually
the docs that are taking the
js.doc and generating
the docs here.
So if I were to click, for
example, on one of them uri's,
what I just described, it's
going to have a nice, pretty
interface where it says these
are the public methods to
it, and it's hiding the
private ones right now.
Some people use that, some
people that are actually coding
with it are using the source
code to look through.
DOM and style, goog.dom,
goog.dom.classes.
There are a lot more things
in there for dealing with
a low level DOM stuff.
Style, the same way,
goog.style, goog.window.
And then for network, all the
things that I described:
formats, goog.json, and then
all sorts of just common things
that you'd expect in a base
library, like goog.Date --
delayed timer, it's
pretty extensive.
UI, I'll just go over this
briefly, but the best thing
to look at is the demos for
everything that's in there.
Just look at the directory
itself; look at the demo's
directory, which is at slash
demo's, when you check it out.
Everything is based, like I
said, on Component; there are
sub-classes of Control and
Container; there's too many,
too exhaustive to list here.
Big picture, it looks
somewhat like this.
We have data structures
and DOM as low-level --
a low-level library.
UI sits on top of that, and
over its own yellow box.
All of the other utilities
of network, random
utilities, miscellaneous.
Finally it's important
to mention that we
keep a test suite.
If I open that up -- this is
actually going to -- it's going
to be faster -- there we go --
so, some of these might go red,
but what is actually doing is
pulling up off of SVN all of
these tests, which actually sit
in HTML files, and then are
pulling in the necessary
things, exercising them,
and reporting back whether
they succeeded or failed.
And so we have infrastructure
internally that is doing this
continuously, so when people
check in, we know what breaks
and we also do it as a submit
queue, so that we know that
you don't break anything
when you submit.
I could go into one of these
examples, but basically if you
open up the HTML file, it's
just a test bed for it to be
able to run these things in the
browser, and the important
thing about that is
the next slide.
So there's a module called
goog.testing that has all sorts
of asserts and handling of
asynchronicity, mocking tools,
things like that, that you
would expect in a test suite,
and then what's important
is the test runner.
In our -- in Google we have a
test runner that is constantly
running to, be able to run
these in different browsers.
So especially for things that
don't impact the Dom, it's kind
of odd that it would work
on one and not the other?
Well, there are cases like the
way they handle extra comma in
an array, which is annoying,
but it's constantly fanning out
and running them on a suite of
browsers that are just
existing in a farm.
Running all these tests
continuously and then
letting us know if anything
breaks, makes sense?
The future, Google
and open source.
So one of our efforts was
an open-source versus
published source code.
Our efforts was to extricate
it from our build environment
internally, to license it
and then publish that code.
That was our priority.
Closure library was not started
with the intention of being
open source one day, and
actually Books did -- you know,
did a lot of JavaScript work
before Closure Library exists,
and is was poured
into it later.
And so I'm not even one of the
original authors, but like I
said, lots of internal build
system and it's been difficult
for us to have non-Google code
in the repository, but as part
of this, we have been working
with the open source project
office to try to
get around this.
So I can announce that we
can take patches today.
This is something that
a lot of people have
-- what's been annoying --
[APPLAUSE]
NATHAN NAZE: What's been
annoying for people outside and
inside is that people report
bugs and include a patch, and
we say, for legal reasons,
we can't take that and
check it into Perforce.
We can now.
So if you actually go and look
at the source today, the
copyright statements have been
changed from copyright Google
to copyright the Closure
Library authors.
We have an Office file, and we
can take patches, read them in
and a Google Engineer will
apply them and put
them internally.
Part of MOE, the Make Open Easy
Project, is to automate that
process so it's less onerous.
So we're looking forward to
that, and that also -- I looked
at the way -- some of the
questions that were asked
before this even started was
-- I'd like to see this
functionality, I'd like to see
that functionality, and it's
been hard, because I always
want to say, "Write it
yourself." And now I can.
So this is always on -- Google
groups have always been Closure
Library Compiler templates
discuss -- lot of traffic them,
I would encourage
you to join them.
And also we want to try to --
like I said, it was our effort
to get this thing over the wall
and to push it out there.
We now want to foster the
community, so we're starting up
a blog, which different
Engineers that are working
either on -- on any of the
tools on Compiler Library or
templates, we'll post notes and
things up there, and also a
twitter account, which will -
articles that we see, interact
with people in the community,
and also as a just
a way to interact.
And those are the
announcements.
So I should just bring up the
Closure tools blog, right here.
It also has links off on the
side to all of th e things that
you'd care to know about, so
the home, the source -- so
Compiler, for example, has a
web service, which is a cool
thing, that you can actually do
this instead of having the
binary locally, you send it to
an app, and to an app that will
compile it for you, which is
fun, because you just click
"Compile,"
and it does it.
But on top of that, that
should largely be it.
So the twitter account, we set
it up, so let's do, alert,
hello world, first post.
There you go.
That should be it.
So you can follow that or you
can follow us -- so actually,
the funny thing is Google
Reader -- the two ironic points
are: this presentation was done
in google.docs in our
presentations thing, which is
written on Closure Library, so
it's circular in that way and
also, if you follow us
on Reader, that's also
written on Closure tools.
So let me go to the Wave, if
anybody had questions during
this, and also I should go to
the Q&A slide as well.
So the Wave, the url
is right there.
If anybody has questions,
please come up to the
microphone in the middle
so we can all hear you.
And I should also mention that
Closure Compiler, we'll all be
having office hours today in
Space B from 2:30 - 5:00.
I'll also be there, and feel
free if you see me walking
outside -- I'll be wearing a
nametag with my name on it,
just grab me, and
ask me questions.
So thank you.
I guess we'll start with -- I'm
going to switch back and forth
between what's on the Wave and
what's on the mic,
but please...
SPEAKER1: I have a question
about how does it integrate
with jQuery and Google web
toolkit and is there anything
we need to specifically do in
order to make it work, any
problems, do you recommend
it, things like that...
NATHAN NAZE: I'm sorry.
So one of the things is that --
as a design choice, we don't do
anything to modify, and this is
a problem in other toolkits.
We want to do nothing that
would impede your ability
to pull in something else.
So the major thing there is
squash anything in the global
scope or modify anything
expected not to be there
on the prototype.
So some JavaScript libraries
will do this; they will add
functions to the array
prototype or to the function
prototype that actually in the
case -- some of them actually
squash things that are in
JavaScript 1.6, which
was a problem.
So you could definitely
use them both.
We have talked about how do we
try to integrate GWT and there
is functional overlap; we don't
really have -- we've talked
about it, we don't have any
particular plans, but there is
no reason you couldn't bring
jQuery in, use that -- there is
a query engine in Closure
Compiler, but if you'd prefer
to bring in jQuery use that to
pull in a DOM object, give that
to something in Closure, there
would be no reason
you couldn't.
SPEAKER1: So do we need
to namescape, I mean,
namespace a jQuery, or...
NATHAN NAZE: Yeah, so the
jQuery is just going to be
something -- as long as it
doesn't interfere with anything
in the global scope, so like I
said, everything is -- for us,
everything is behind this goog
namespace in the top level and
there shouldn't -- let me know
if you find anything that sits
anywhere else, so it
shouldn't interact.
The only thing that would be
a negative interaction is
something else did something
to modify a prototype,
something like that, so...
SPEAKER1: Thank you.
NATHAN NAZE: Yup.
So that actually is the Wave
that's on this too, because
some people were asking
questions remotely.
So, one of them was actually
related to this, which was
interactions between -- which
I just answered --
GWT and Closure.
Yeah, so another
one from the mic.
SPEAKER2: So this morning I saw
this speed tracer thing in GWT
Does it make sense, is Closure,
Closure going to have the
same thing as well, or...
NATHAN NAZE: So some of the
things you can do you are -- so
if you look through the library
there are things to be able to
do instrumentation, you can
also use Page Speed, to do, to
find places that you could
speed up your code, what's
taking too long to load.
One of the other questions in
there is -- can you describe
the best way to split a large
code base up into multiple
dynamically loaded modules
in a way that resembles
GWT'S code-splitting.
So a lot of applications today
like gmail will actually -- in
docs you will notice this, that
it loads in stages, that
it's doing modules.
That's one of the ways; it's a
pretty advanced topic, but the
way that's done is that there
are command line arguments to
the Compiler where you can
specify, this should be
compiled into module one; this,
module two, it's a pretty
advanced topic, we should --
what we'll probably do is do a
blog post, specifically
on this, so...
Yeah, I hope that
answers your question.
Is there anything else on here
-- does anybody share any
of the questions that are
on here that's in line?
Can you provide a
public roadmap?
I should answer.
So one of the things is that we
try to have all of our
discussions on Closure Library
Discuss about what we're
planning on doing next.
So things right now, things
that we've been prioritizing
are the announcements for
today, the ability
to take patches.
But I think one of the things
we'd also like to do is start
organizing things and getting a
list of wants, what people want
to pull into the library or
implement in the library, and
either get people inside Google
or outside Google
working on those.
For the mic...
SPEAKER3:
Yeah, actually comparing your
Library to others like jQuery,
that's not actually my
question, but just a comment --
an appropriate question would
be the scope of your Library
versus the scope -- what are
they -- because people tend to
pick libraries, and then if
yours is very comprehensive
-- it looks good to me.
I've done a lot of
JavaScript [INAUDIBLE]
coding.
Looks like I'll start to take a
look at this and maybe that
will become my -- what I use,
assuming it has complete
coverage of most of the
things I want to do.
NATHAN NAZE: Right.
SPEAKER3: Okay, let me ask my
question also and you can
answer both -- a very
basic question.
I haven't -- I've done plenty
of JavaScript -- I've coded in
Java in other worlds, but
I haven't used GWT yet.
My understanding is GWT enables
you to program in Java, and
gets compiled to JavaScript,
so, and you mentioned gmail --
I understand gmail's
a GWT application.
NATHAN NAZE:
Gmail is primarily written
on top of Closure tools.
SPEAKER3: That answers
that question.
Okay, so it's more
direct JavaScript.
NATHAN NAZE: Yeah.
That's one of the things is --
so there's two points there.
One is that this is a broad
and complex library, and
it's intended for a very
specific purpose, so
the scope is different.
It's, also the intended
purpose is different.
So it's like, what is
better Python or Java?
The answer is both.
We're -- there are
things -- oh, go ahead.
SPEAKER3: I meant gmail,
the gmail application.
NATHAN NAZE: Right.
SPEAKER3: Is it written in GWT?
NATHAN NAZE: No.
SPEAKER3: Good, okay.
NATHAN NAZE: But what I what
I'm saying is that there are
differences between Closure
Library and the things that it
was specifically designed for
and, you know, there are cases
in my day to day programming
life that I'm going to choose
Java for a variety of reasons,
there's cases I'm going to pick
Python for a variety of
reasons; same issue with
Closure Library versus jQuery
and/or any other JavaScript
library out there.
A lot of projects at Google use
jQuery A lot projects at Google
-- a lot of projects,
especially things that aren't
things like, you know, Google
apps, Google docs, things like
that; but there are a lot of
projects that actually are
using other libraries at
Google, depending
on their purpose.
Next question.
SPEAKER4: Yes, I'm doing a
fairly complex medical imaging
project, and we've decided to
go with Google Closure as
opposed to jQuery, and the
experience so far has been very
difficult, because we find
the documentation for the
API, it's very lacking.
NATHAN NAZE: Mhm.
SPEAKER4: And a lot of the
times even the demo's don't
work like they're
supposed to do.
So I'm just wondering, there's
a better place than the public
API where we could find how
they work, and if not, are you
planning on improving
on the documentation.
NATHAN NAZE: So, two things.
One is so like I said, this is
all -- so one of the things is
we wanted to do in this
development in the public
realm; so it's all 20
percenters, so we don't have
any full time staff that is
writing down documentation.
The two things I would
recommend you do are: complain,
go to Closure Library Discuss,
say, I don't understand how to
do this, because we don't know
it's broken, if nobody reports
back and we don't have
that feedback loop.
So like I said, I'm one of a
lot of Engineers that work on
this and they all
read that thing.
What you don't realize is that
if you go and post on there, a
lot of the original authors of
Closure's all going to read
it and respond to it.
We've also opened up the
wiki for public comment.
We'd actually like people to --
what -- we have some internal
documentation, and we try to
take that and put that on the
wiki, but for pain
points, especially, we'd
like to know more.
One of the things is that
inside the generated API docs,
just taken from the JS doc that
you see on -- in the code, most
of the time when people are
working internally, they just
have eMacs windows open and
they are looking at this from
the left and looking
on the right.
The code should be the source
of what you're looking at,
because it's going to be the
one -- the best-documented.
That's what most Engineers on
-- that are using Closure
internally are doing.
Right?
Thank you.
SPEAKER5: Good afternoon.
NATHAN NAZE: Hi.
SPEAKER5: Concerning open
sourcing closer, what kind of
patches are you guys looking
for, only bug fixes or
new patches, like...
NATHAN NAZE: So, so...
SPEAKER5: Because we don't want
to work too hard developing new
patches and, all of the sudden,
oh, we don't accept this patch.
How do we know what will
be accepted, and...
NATHAN NAZE: Right so obviously
things that are minor bux
fixes, there's not going to be
a whole lot of contention.
If you -- so one of the things
I'd like to do on the external
discussion list is
identify things.
You know, this is the module
I'd like to put in, I have
some interest in this.
Bring it up on the thread,
because everybody's
going to copy on that.
Do that as an initial thing.
Even inside of Google, like, a
change list of more than 300
lines is kind of odd, because
you know, this happens in the
open source community, where
somebody like, goes off,
branches something, comes in
with 10,000 lines of like, I've
written you a new whatever.
SPEAKER5: Split them
up in diffferent...
NATHAN NAZE: Right, exactly.
Because that way you're getting
feedback along the way.
One of the things about the
culture of coding inside
of Google is, you know,
continuous integration.
So people are submitting what
they wrote and -- continuous
integration and also,
code reviewing.
So we bounce it, you know,
before anything goes in at
Google, before anything goes
into Closure Library, we're
doing a continual review of --
like, did you consider this
case, this is a matched style,
you know, by convention
we do this, to try to
maintain a good API.
SPEAKER6: Are you -- are
patches -- sorry - are
contributors allowed
to commit over time?
Are you accepting external
committers... with
Closure Library?
NATHAN NAZE: So one of the
issues is is -- so we're just
starting up on this now so the
way that -- I don't know at
what point -- it would not be
my decision, it would be a
decision of everybody about how
we're going to handle
upgrading people to
just committer status.
One of the issues is [? MOE ?]
is a nascent project, so the
ability to make submissions to
the external SVN and pull them
into Perforce, we need to
figure that process out better.
Right now it's probably just
going to be sending a patch
and working with an email.
We're yet to do -- you know, so
far it's been announced for 15
minutes now, so we don't have
the policy quite written, but
it's something we have to do.
Bring it up on the list would
probably be the best answer,
and I think we have
one more question.
SPEAKER7: Both YUI#3 and...
NATHAN NAZE: Uh, can you
uh, right in the mic?
SPEAKER7: Yeah, both
YUI3 and Closure and
dependency resolution.
Doesn't that actually inspire
more bandwith, rather than
less, if your application is
multiple-page, because as you
make your JS binary, you are
including different
dependencies and creating this
large, monolithic file, per
page, so you have no, like,
re-useability as far as just
those particular
script modules.
They would be re-transmitted
every time, right?
NATHAN NAZE: No,
it's a fair point.
The other option is to always
do per module, you know, this
page only uses this and just
pulls whatever, but you're
still getting into the problem
of having a whole bunch of HTTP
requests going back and forth.
Some people handle this by
writing different binaries for
each page; some people handle
this by trying to manage it as
multiple components, so that
there is a base module, and
then what's additional
for this page.
The nice thing about that is
that the base module is
cacheable, and then the other
one is just loaded
incrementally.
But, yeah, it's a hard
problem in general, I agree.
SPEAKER7: Just the bandwith and
the actual JIT reinterpretation
of the new file would be rather
expensive, it feels like.
NATHAN NAZE: To do
it just in time?
SPEAKER7: Well, so if you keep
a file in cache, like your
monolithic jQuery or whatever,
if the browser is smart enough,
it can keep that compilation of
it, too, so you might
consider that, too.
NATHAN NAZE: Yup.
so, I mean this is part of the
logic of the Google Ajax API,
is that if everybody uses the
same URL, they have that one
consistently cached, and then
if that's widely used on the
internet, we don't pay
that cost every time that
people use, and it's a
completely fair point.
I am 41 seconds over, so
I'll have to let you go.
Thank you very much.